we'll some ancient messages just never
be read no matter how hard we try
history's got something to hide from you
that's okay because last time we armed
you with a new skill decipherment you're
ready to go just point you in a
direction but what to decipher oh I
really wish I could remember the book
but in a library in Ithaca there is or
there was some book with a neat graph
that breaks down the problem for us
bloop down a chart with two axes yep a
chart we're getting into this now look
at a script and ask yourself two simple
questions can I read the graphics and do
I know the language if you know how to
read the writing system but not the
language you can learn the language if
you have enough samples in some way of
reading into those samples a little
translation here a familiar name there
just to crack open the doorway for you a
good example is North Pi seen these
ancient northern Italians carved their
language into the novel our Estella and
we can read it sort of what I mean is we
can sound out the graphemes
but practically since there aren't many
North Pi seeing texts lying around for
us to learn from we don't know what this
says don't cry think about known
languages with known writing systems
they're easy if you can already read the
graphemes
and the language it's simple recognition
tasks oh that's Swahili written in the
Latin alphabet and there's Swahili
written in the arabic abjad wow we
really need to cover these writing terms
what about languages we don't know
written in writing systems we can't read
who possibly impossible with enough of
the right kinds of examples we can
figure out a language from a script or a
script from a language but if we're
missing both this square breaks last
times model of decipherment we're left
with one lone box known language unknown
writing systems this is our box in this
box we find all of the decipherment of
the past and those taunting mysteries
still waiting to be cracked this is the
realm of brilliant hunches that made
history and crank theories that went
nowhere stay tuned and subscribe for
tales of decipherment
you